we are now meeting informally
as i informed the house earlier given
the exceptional and grave situation i've
agreed to a request from president
zielenski of the ukraine
to address members of this house about
the situation in this country
that is why i have suspended the formal
business of the house in order to hear
the president's address
we have also been joined by the ukraine
ambassador
president selensky we have watched the
situation unfolding your country with
increasing concern but also with
increasing admiration for the knowledge
the fortitude displayed by you
opinions
mr president
you're welcome to address members of the
house of commons and the lords you now
have the floor president
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
mr speaker missed um
all the members of parliament
ladies and gentlemen
i'm addressing all the people of the
united kingdom
and all the people
from the country with a big history
i'm addressing you as a citizen as a
president
of also a big country
with a dream
and big effort
i would like to tell you about the three
days of
about the 13 days of war
the war that we didn't start
and we didn't want it
however we have to conduct this war
we do not want to lose
what we have what is ours our country
ukraine
just the same way as you once didn't
want to lose your country when nazis
started to
fight your country
and you had to fight for britain 13 days
of this struggle
on day one at four o'clock in the
morning we were attacked by cruise
missiles
[Music]
everybody woke up
people were children
the entire ukraine and since that we
have not been sleeping
we have all been fighting
for our country with our army
on day two
we have been fighting airstrikes and our
heroic
military servicemen on the islands
mainly have been trying to fight
when russian
flag
uh the
russian forces demanded that we lay down
the arms
however
we did continue fighting and
and we did we did feel
our force
um the fourth of our people that will
oppose their occupants until until the
end
the next day the aotearoa artillery
started fighting us
the
our army showed
us
who we are and
we we have been able to see who are
people and who are best
now on day four we started uh getting
people captive
we have not been torturing them
we
remained humane
even on day four of this
against children against cities
and
constant shelling have been taking place
around the country including hospitals
and that didn't break us
and that gave us feeling
of big truth
[Music]
on day six
the russian um
rockets felt on baby yard that is the
place where the nazis
killed
thousands of people during the second
world war
uh and eighty years after the russia
hit at them for the second time
and even um churches are getting
destroyed
by shelling
on day eight
we have seen russian tanks hitting
the
atomic power station
and everybody got to understand that
this is the terror against
everyone
on day nine there was a meeting of nato
congress
without the
result that we were looking for
yes we did feel
that we did feel
that
um we did feel that unfortunately that
the alliances
don't work properly always
and the no-fly zone cannot be enforced
and on day 10 the
ukrainians started protesting
and mass
stopping the um
armored vehicles with their own hands
and on day 11
the
children and cities were being hit and
hospitals as well with the rockets and
constant shelling
and on that day we realized that europe
ukrainians became heroes
the entire cities children adults
and on day 12
the
losses of
russian army exceeded 10 000
people killed
and also including the general and that
gave us hope
that there will be some kind of
responsibility for those people
of uh
in front of the court on day 13
in
a child
they do not allow any food any water
and people started panicking
i
i think everybody
can hear that
that
people do not have water over there over
13 days of this
situation
over 50
children have been killed
these are the children that could have
lived
but these people have taken them away
from us
the united kingdom
ukraine were not looking to have this
form
the ukraine have not been looking to
become
big but they have become big over the
days
of this war
the we are the country that are saving
people despite
[Music]
despite having to fight the one of the
biggest country one of the biggest
armies in the world
we have to fight the helicopters rockets
the question for us now is to be or not
to be oh no this shakespearean
question
for 13 days this question
could have been asked
but now i can give you a definitive
answer it's definitely yes to be
um
and i would like to remind you the words
that the united kingdom have already
heard
which are important again
we will not
give up and we will not lose
we will
fight till the end at sea
in the air
we will continue fighting for our land
whatever the cost
we will fight in the forests in the
fields
on the shores
in the streets
i would like to add
that we will fight
on the on the banks of different rivers
like nipper
and we will
we are looking
for your help
for the help of the civilized
countries
we are well for this help
and we
and i'm very grateful to you
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and please recognize this
country as a terrorist state
and please make sure that our ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
that
you do
what needs to be done
and
what is stipulated by the greatness of
your country
best of all to ukraine and
to the united kingdom
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mr president on behalf of the
house of commons i want i want to thank
you for speaking to us and for giving us
very clearly and powerful perspective
the tragic situation facing you and
fellow ukrainians
we have debated the situation in ukraine
numerous times in recent weeks
and i know that we will continue to do
so and that when we do so
you're
working with us
i want to express the solidarity of the
house of commons with you your
compatriots
and we salute the courage of the people
of ukraine
thank you and our prayers are with you
mr speaker
we'll now resume with the formal
settings of the house order order i will
take the punch of order from the leaders
of the main parties before we return to
the opposition day i called the prime
minister thank you mr speaker
a point of order with your permission mr
speaker man i said never before in all
our centuries of our parliamentary
democracy has the house listened to such
an address
in a great european capital now within
range of russian guns president vladimir
zolensky is standing firm for democracy
and for freedom
in his righteous defense i believe he
has moved the hearts of everybody in
this house
at this moment ordinary ukrainians are
defending their homes and their families
against a brutal ass
and they are by their actions inspiring
millions by their courage and their
devotion and i think today one of the
proudest boasts in the free world is yah
ukraine i am a ukrainian so this is a
moment for us to put our political
differences aside mr speaker and i know
i speak for the whole house when i say
the britain and our allies are
determined to press on
to press on with supplying our ukrainian
friends with the weapons they need to
defend their homeland as they deserve
to press on with tightening the economic
vice around vladimir putin and we will
stop importing russian oil mr speaker my
right honourable friend the business
secretary will update the house on that
tomorrow and we will employ every method
that we can diplomatic humanitarian and
economic mr speaker until vladimir putin
has failed in this disastrous venture
and ukraine is free once more
on a point of order mr speaker every one
of us has been moved by the bravery the
resolve and the leadership of president
zielenski
invading troops marched through his
streets
shells rained down on his people
an assassin seek his life
no one would have blamed him for fleeing
but instead he has stayed in kiev to
lead the ukrainian people and to
fight he's reminded us that our freedom
and our democracy are invaluable
he's prompted the world into action
where too often we've let putin have his
way
he's inspired the ukrainian people to
resist and frustrated the russian war
machine
he has shown his strength
and we must show him
and the ukrainian people our commitment
and our support
labor stands for the unity at home and
abroad that will isolate the putin
regime
labour stands for the toughest sanctions
that will [ __ ] the russian state
labour stands for providing ukraine with
the arms it needs to fight off their
invaders
labour stands with president zielenski
with ukraine with democracy
slava ukraine
thank you
thank you mr speaker with your
performance if i can make a point of
order president zielinski
we salute you
we stand with the people of ukraine
on the basis of the
act of aggression
on the act of war
of putin
we must do all that we can
to send support to ukraine to send the
weapons that they need to defend
themselves
to make sure
that we
sanction
the regime in moscow that we deliver the
clearest message to president putin
that this will end in failure for him
that he will face justice at the
international court we must stand
in this house
throughout these islands throughout the
western world
in defense of democracy
in defense of sovereignty
peace
justice
and the sovereignty
of ukraine
must prevail
let's make sure
that we stand with our friends we stand
against those that have been bombed
we make sure that those that need our
support that need our sanctuary
will find the welcoming hand
in these islands
mr president
we thank you
we salute you
slavia ukraine
david point of order mr speaker
hearing the words of president zelinski
should embolden us all
they serve as a reminder of all that we
stand for
of all which so many ukrainians are so
bravely
fighting for
are bravery exemplified by president
zielinski himself
that we should never take for granted
our values of democracy of freedom and
of our security
and though we in this house may disagree
on many things we stand together for
those values and together we stand
together with
the ukrainian people
mr speaker
it is right that we strengthen our
support for ukraine
with military aid
with toughest of sanctions
and it's in that support that we should
also recognize the people of ukraine and
indeed president salenski i'm sure the
whole house would agree
that president zlensky should be granted
one of our nation's highest honors an
honorary knighthood and i look forward
to the day when we welcome back to this
house president zelinski in person
so jeffrey donaldson
thank you mr speaker on the point of
order
we
command president zielenski and the
people of ukraine and we stand with them
in this uh their time of strife but our
response will not be judged by the
volume or strength of our applause for
president zielinski it will be judged by
the volume and strength of our response
to his request for help for practical
military support and for humanitarian
assistance for the people of ukraine
we pray for their success we dare not
let them down
can i also like to thank the staff and
the contractors for making this happen
and when you leave the chamber can you
please hand in your headsets on the way
out
who you got them from
i will now let the chamber clear thank
you everybody